you mentioned quantum mechanics
and we're talking about
cosmic scale objects you've talked about
that the evolution of astrophysical
disks can be modeled with
uh schrodinger's equation i sure did
why like how does quantum mechanics
uh become relevant at when you
uh consider the evolution of objects in
the solar system yeah
well let me take a take a step back and
just say like i remember
being you know utterly confused
by quantum mechanics when i first
learned it and
the schrodinger equation which is kind
of the parent equation
of of that whole field you know it seems
to come out of nowhere
right the way that the way that i was
sort of explaining it i remember asking
you know my professor is like but where
does it come from is that like well just
just like don't worry about it and just
like calculate the
hydrogen you know energy levels right so
it's like i could do all the problems i
just did not have any intuition for
for where this parent you know super
important equation came from now down
the line i was
remember i was preparing for my own
lecture and i was trying to understand
how waves travel in self-gravitating
disks
so you know again
there's a very broad theory that's
already developed but i was
looking for some simpler way to explain
it really
for the purposes of teaching class and
so i i thought okay
what if i just imagine a disc as an
infinite
uh number of concentric circles right
that interact with
the with each other gravitationally
that's a problem in some sense that um
i can solve using methods from like the
late 1700s right so i can write down
hamiltonian well i can write down the
energy function basically of their their
interactions
and what i
found is that when you take the
continuum limit when you
go from discrete circles that are
talking to each other gravitationally to
a
continuum disk suddenly
this gravitational interaction among
them
right the the governing equation becomes
the schrodinger equation
and i had to think about that for a
little bit did you just unify
quantum mechanics and gravity no this is
not the same thing
as like you know fusing relativity and
quantum mechanics
but it did uh it did get me thinking a
little bit
so the fact that waves in astrophysical
disks
behave just like wave functions of
of particles kind of like an interesting
analogy because for me it's easier to
imagine waves traveling through you know
astrophysical disks or really just
sheets of paper and
the reason this is that analogy exists
it's because there's actually nothing
quantum
about the schrodinger equation the
schrodinger equation is
just a wave equation and all of the
interpretation
that comes from it is quantum
but the equation itself is not a
quantum being so you can use it to model
waves
wait it's not turtles it's waves all the
way down you can pick which level you
pick the
wave at so it could be at the solar
system level that you can use right
and also it actually provides a pretty
neat calculational tool
because um it's difficult so we
just talked about simulations but it's
difficult to simulate
the behavior of astrophysical disks on
time
scales that are in between
a few orbits and their entire evolution
so it's over a time scale of a few
orbits
you have you do a hydrodynamic you know
simulation
right you do that basically that's
something that you can do
on a modern computer on a time scale of
say a week
when it comes to their evolution over
their entire lifetime you don't hope to
resolve the orbits you just kind of
hope to understand how the system
behaves in between
right you to get access to that as it
turns out it's pretty
um it's pretty cute you can use uh you
can use the schrodinger equation to get
the answer
rapidly so it's a calculational tool
you